[Musique]
c'est au jardin botanique à saint-leu
que l'université de la réunion en
partenariat avec le département ont
organisé pour la rentrée de 200
étudiants étrangers
une visite du jardin une après midi
d'échangés culturels et pédagogiques
évidemment c'est un certain nombre de
groupes donc nos étudiants sont là ils
sont ravis d'être là et surtout c'était
pour nous important de pouvoir après la
cérémonie de ce matin officiel où était
présente d'ailleurs la vice présidente
du conseil départemental
voilà et où nous avons préservé
présenter les services de l'université
leur montrer et bien un lieu qui soit à
la fois culturel et scientifique
voilà puisque nous avons ici la
possibilité d'avoir deux fabuleuses
collections et que l'une des niches
d'excellence de l'université c'est la
biodiversité
une visite du jardin botanique qui
permet à ses étudiants de découvrir les
différentes espèces endémiques et
indigènes qui font toute la beauté de
notre île
[Musique]